ian maxwell has said he doesn't think
his sister will flip she won't cooperate
uh with prosecutors in return for a
shorter sentence and he's also conceded
that her conviction will provide victims
with what he called solace and relief
from their pain he does believe these
women were abused by jeffrey epstein
that abuse was horrendous and he
empathizes with them but mr maxwell
believes his sister was not part of it
he he thinks somehow that she was
compartmentalized and caught
compartmentalized away from that abuse
in a pretty frank 45-minute interview he
said he does not believe his sister
received a fair trial partly because she
was refused bail and was incarcerated
for 18 months he said that meant she was
pretty weak too weak he thought to take
the stand and give evidence because
when you're under cross examination you
need to be sharp he argued she was not
in that state because of her treatment
in prison he was also optimistic about
her appeal even though we know it's very
rare for appeals to be successful in the
us
after a federal jury trial now i
challenged mr maxwell on him shedding
doubt on the evidence of these women who
didn't just say they were abused by
jeffrey epstein but that gilley maxwell
was at the heart of
coordinating that abuse that she touched
them inappropriately at points that one
woman said she she told
her to dress up in a schoolgirl's outfit
and delivered her for jeffrey epstein to
abuse but ian maxwell denied he was
victim blaming and said it was up for
other people to decide whether he is
deluded i put it to him that he appeared
to think that his sister was the victim
in all of this and that he did not
believe the four women
i think it's entirely that these women
were victims of jeffrey epstein i think
that's a fact they have been received
compensation from the
uh jeffrey epstein estate
who obviously accepted that they were
victims so i accept
that these accusers were victims of
jeffrey epstein what i do not accept is
that they were victims of guillen
maxwell so mr maxwell you believe these
four women
but
only part of the way because all four of
them said that your sister was part of
the abuse
carolyn said she was 14 when your sister
came in and felt her boobs and her hips
and her buttocks and said she had a
great body for mr epstein and his
friends annie farmer says your sister
told her to get undressed and to get on
the massage table your sister she said
then rubbed
annie farmer's chest and upper breast
jane said your sister was in the room
while epstein sexually abused her and
that your sister touched her breasts
kate says your sister laid out a
schoolgirl outfit on her bed and said i
thought it would be fun for you to take
geoffrey his tea in this outfit kate
said she wore the outfit and epstein had
sex with her all four victims say your
sister was at the heart of the abuse and
you think they're lying well
if if i'm right i don't believe that
they were saying the same thing to the
authorities
two or three years ago guillen's name
didn't suffer
they're confused or what's the
justification it doesn't it doesn't
follow that they are lying
reality is
all of this occurred 25 years ago 20 25
years ago
and uh it is in we know that memory does
funny things we know that
uh lawyers became involved several
lawyers representing the same women the
stories then begin to be starting to
involve guillen
pretty much after the epstein fund
starts to become available so
it seems to me
that there is a fundamental discrepancy
between what was said
in the past and what was said at the
trial it doesn't follow that lies have
been said
people will think mr maxwell that you
are victim blaming and you are
gaslighting these women
i'm certainly not victim blaming that
why would i do that
ian maxwell also told us he does not
think his sister will flip he doesn't
think she will now decide to cooperate
with the prosecutors help them convict
other people in return for reducing her
own likely pretty lengthy prison
sentence this is what ian maxwell told
us in the last couple of hours
i think we know because the prosecution
has said that they have never made her
any offer and she has never made them
any offer
i i
i don't think that's going to change i
don't know what gillan has to to say
about
anyone else i mean you know the position
is that she
uh
her position is that she
uh did not
participate or was aware of these
terrible activities
so her logical position must be that's
to be continued and therefore why is she
suddenly going to start producing names
and who knows what so i don't think
that's going to happen
people will make up their own minds in
this case certainly the jury did
deciding unanimously and beyond
reasonable doubt that gilley maxwell was
guilty of five counts of uh sex
trafficking she's likely to spend the
rest of her life in jail her appeal is
unlikely to be successful ian maxwell
told us that he will stand by his sister
even if she's sentenced to 50 years in
jail i don't think though kimberly many
people were thinking about her future at
the moment but the future of all of the
women who were abused by gillane maxwell
and jeffrey epstein women whose lives
were damaged diminished and in some case
destroyed due to that abuse at least now
they have some semblance of justice